on a là vous êtes là dans la classe les
tableaux blancs interactifs font
désormais partie de la vie des élèves
bonjour sang partout dans toutes les
classes des écoles publiques primaires
et secondaires la journée 240 millions
c'est le coût total du programme dont la
gestion soulève toujours bien des
questions ces manques d légal et
personne qui était responsable et
imputable dans le dossier un des
fournisseurs sort grand gagnant de cette
aventure d'autres s'estime lésé le
milieu scolaire at il été influencé
françois taquet le croire a eu pour leur
argent avec son collègue défensivement
voici un tableau interactif une grande
surface blanche combinée un projecteur
et un portable des françaises
un écran d'ordinateur géant sur lequel
l'enseignant peut donner son cours mais
surtout ça va interagir les élèves comme
ici à sainthia nos jeunes sont attirés
par les nouvelles technologies
à l'hiver 2011 jean charest surprend le
monde de l'éducation annonce que chaque
classe de chaque école du québec soit
dotée d'un tableau blanc intelligent et
que chaque professeur soit muni d'un
ordinateur portable
le gouvernement s'engage à financer
l'achat de tableaux jusqu'à concurrence
de 3000 $ l'unité
un marché énorme s'ouvre aux
fournisseurs smart technology embauche
même le lobbyiste martin daraîche ex
conseiller politique de jean charest ni
lui ni ce maïs n'ont voulu préciser la
nature exacte de son mandat d'autres
compagnies de produits interactifs se
lance aussi dans la course pour équiper
les écoles du québec
c'est vraiment une bonne idée mais
personne ne savait dans quoi on
s'embarque restant lol c'est inhabituel
pour des fournisseurs de critiquer un
gros clients comme le gouvernement mais
nous en avons convaincu plusieurs de
nous parler
on peut reconnaître la tête
on peut revenir est inséré un logo grand
pile on aurait bien aimé montrer tout ce
que son dispositif mobile peut faire qui
est une barre et mater pour monter sur
un tableau sa part est aussi montée sur
un autre argument de vente sont produits
toute une fraction du prix d'un tableau
interactif standard bonjour gagnerait
divan elle aussi un produit mobile de
petite taille qui peut être déplacé
d'une classe à l'autre selon les besoins
je souhaitais je peux naviguer mais par
contre je peux également à noter elle
nous présente son produit entre mel
aurait voulu faire auprès des
responsables du gouvernement n'avaient
jamais participé à un banc d'essai un
banc de ce nom on approcherait des 4,1
puis je l'attends toujours l'invitation
de présenter avez vous été appelés à
soumettre un démo au ministère de
l'éducation
pas du tout on veut contrôler les
fournisseurs n'en reviennent toujours
pas que le gouvernement n'est pas évalué
les technologies existantes à l'époque
je vois la chance d'aller au bal
car on n'a pas la chance de l'eau bat
c'est là je trouve que cette entreprise
de victoriaville fabrique des tableaux
depuis 80 ans
c'est vraiment très versatile en 2011
elle se lance dans les tableaux
interactifs
si on parle de durabilité une surface de
porcelaine
et indestructible on s'est fait dire
c'est que on ne préfère pas vous
rencontrer monsieur alain parce que on
ne voudrait pas eu d'influencé
si vous écrivez un appel d'offres sur un
produit vous devez vous référer à
quelque chose on l'inventé pas le
produit le gouvernement choisit le
centre de services partagés du québec le
cspq pour gérer cet appel d'offres cet
organisme public chargé de magasiner
pour les ministères a été vivement
critiquée ces dernières années pour son
manque d'efficacité et de rigueur pour
le programme des tableaux il doit
préparer un catalogue de produits
interactifs
mais encore une fois il ne sera pas à la
hauteur
je dois avoir presque deux pieds de
documents sur mes tablettes pour un
processus d'appel d'offres je pense
qu'on n'a jamais autant travaillé chaque
année ont doublé novembre dominique
labrousse souvent lui aussi des tableaux
avant même le programme de jean charest
son actif boyd est déjà présent dans les
écoles du québec aux côtés du tableau ce
mic son principal compétiteur il
entrevoit des affaires d'or plus on
avait le vent dans les voiles depuis on
était rendu appropriée à 43 44 % du
marché
mais le catalogue mise en place par le
gouvernement connaît des ratés je
pensais d art essai de l'expliquer à des
acheteurs commencent à retrouver mon
produit par mais c'est plus de toi mais
line 2
des derniers je vous dirais qu'il ya une
espèce de chaos débutait pas efficace
les gens s'y mettait des produits et ont
soumissionné avec un produit qui dédie
ce contenu est donc cette tanière et
découvre un intrus dans sa catégorie
dispositif léger de moins de 100 g des
gros tableau à roulettes qui pèse 250
livres
ils ont décidé de suspendre notre
catégorie exactement dans les périodes
où ce qu'est tout le monde passer leur
commande donc uniquement dérive port on
essaie de voir qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le marché il ya un cafouillage vous
en avez vendu convié la première année
donc nous de novembre 2011 à léa au mois
d'avril ou avril 2000 2012
d'abord on n'a rien vendu 0
pas étonnant les commissions scolaires
magazine ailleurs elle cogne à la porte
du regroupement d'achat des cégeps et
csrd le début du iii g
cinquante sept commissions scolaires sur
72 s'y précipitent pour par leurs achats
c'est beaucoup plus simple on peut
choisir directement le tableau le plus
connu à l'époque smite et en prime un
décolleté une ristourne en argent en
suisse est une année très difficile pour
les fournisseurs présents uniquement
dans le catalogue du gouvernement c'est
la catastrophe parce que la première
année est déterminante
le choix de cette première année va
déterminer finalement la plantation pour
le reste et 3 4 ans finalement de toute
la technologie parce que les directeurs
des services informatiques
l'on former leur personnel sur ce jury
technologies au niveau des enseignants
on va les former aussi jachère celui
marien contre le cspq par contre où je
suis un peu aigre s'efface au ccs est
requis pour ma part a pas joué franc jeu
en pourquoi dit que c'était juste et
équitable pour tous les fournisseurs non
ont subi un préjudice espionné justice
ces entrepreneurs ont-ils raison nous
avons posé la question à un avocat
expert ah oui oui ça je peux le dire
absolument les fournisseurs auraient eu
une cause à l'époque s'arrête un très
beau dossier
d'abord le ccf et revend les tableaux
smart en vertu d'un appel d'offres prévu
pour deux cent mille dollars de tableau
or après l'annnonce de jean charest il
en vend pour 10 millions le nombre de
commandes qui sont passés par cet appel
d'offres la a effectivement explose
à son avis le ccsr aurait dû procéder à
un nouvel appel d'offres de son côté
l'organisme dit qu'il devait respecter
ses obligations
on ne pouvait pas mettre fin à un
contrat du jour au lendemain sans
d'abord en mesurer tous les impacts
prendre le risque nous mêmes on se fait
poursuivre par nos propres pour nous
fournisseur pour fans comprend notre
expert constate que les commissions
scolaires achètent pour des centaines de
milliers de dollars sans faire jouer la
concurrence
je pense qu'il ya un gros problème au
niveau du respect de la loi sur les
contrats des organismes publics
et le grand responsable de cette
confusion c'est le ministère de
l'éducation qui autorise les commissions
scolaires à faire leurs achats aux deux
endroits les tableaux l'un était les
gens qui ont été achetés sont ceux de
smart technologies
les commissions scolaires sont des
autorités indépendantes autonomes au
printemps 2012 la grogne est telle que
le gouvernement arrête tout il force le
csr et le cspq à gérer ensemble le
programme d'achat des tableaux quelques
mois plus tard le parti québécois prend
le pouvoir
la nouvelle ministre d'éducation
interpellé au sujet des tableaux
commande un rapport indépendant sur le
programme
le document comprend qu'un indicateur
qui signale en rouge ce qui ne va pas et
du rouge en a partout et là je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait eu des
erreurs tout au long du parcours
parmi les lacunes soulevées dans le
rapport
pas de banc d'essai en raison de
l'urgence manque de planification de
consultation absence d'objectifs clairs
et de connaissances sur les tableaux
interactifs au gouvernement alors
franchement j'étais moi tu paies fait et
est en colère moi je crois qu'à partir
du moment où le premier ministre jean
charest a dit je veux presque j'ordonne
que tout les écoles et ça dans des
délais très brefs obligatoirement pour
mettre ça en marche il fallait faire fi
des principes de bonne gestion
elle regrette de ne pas avoir fait toute
la lumière sur cette affaire avant son
départ de la vie politique
mais nous avons appris que le dossier a
été transmis à l'upac
smart a gagné la guerre des tableaux en
équipant jusqu'à 80% des classes du
québec
donc le tout ce qu'on peut écrire on
peut sauvegarder renault reconnaît les
avantages de son tableau mais comme
enseignant il aurait voulu être
consultée
ça nous était imposé à tout le monde
le programme murmure pour lui
l'interactivité n'a pas nécessairement
la cote auprès des élèves du secondaire
un ailleurs qui va aller vers pour
écrire c'est toujours les mêmes qui vont
venir quand on est ronde ou secondaire
le les programmes sont super charger on
eu beaucoup de la terre à passer il
constate que le plein potentiel du
tableau n'est pas utilisé son
utilisation se limite tu veux être un
écrin où on va projeter ce conte aux
ordinateurs
une étude toute récente de l'université
de montréal lui donnent raison
les enseignants surtout au secondaire
utilisent peu les fonctions interactives
du tableau et déplore le manque de
formation
on a payé pour une belle technologie
qu'on n'utilise pas assez
la stratégie commerciale de ce meurtre a
été des plus efficaces ce m'arrêter de
tous les congrès important depuis des
années pour séduire le milieu scolaire
l'image est vraiment très très très très
clair lors du dernier congrès des
gestionnaires de technologie des
commissions scolaires on pouvait
découvrir le nouveau tableau ce match on
élimine deux projecteurs le moniteur le
visuel est souvent plus intéressant
qu'avec un projecteur et ça coûte
combien dans les alentours de 5200 $
canadiens
les entreprises veulent convaincre
particulièrement les gens du secteur
informatique soit les techniciens
informatiques directement ou les
directeurs informatiques des commissions
scolaires saison qu'on soit on prend des
décisions mais difficile pour les petits
fournisseurs de faire leur place dans
les grands congrès c'était difficile au
début dé rentrer dans ses conclusions
c'était très restreint pour un nombre
limité de exposants
lorsqu'il tente de participer à un
congrès ce fournisseur se bute à
l'intransigeance des organisateurs de
l'événement dont le commanditaire
principal heath marque et on s'est fait
dire de façon catégorique à plusieurs
fois que
avaient pris place donc pour contrer son
nul ou une salade au même endroit mais
dans une salle parallèle donc notre est
pas très loin et les organisateurs qui
ont s'est présentée nous autres
simplement dit qu'on n'avait pas
d'affaires à se présenter lors que ce
n'est des mains privées et qu'on n'était
pas bienvenu tout simplement pour
bienvenue à cet endroit là même qu'on ne
rencontre et la majorité des acheteurs
qui ont fait confiance à notre produit
dans ces congrès une entreprise peut
aussi donner des ateliers comme ici lors
d'une réunion des cadres scolaires
on procède ensuite un tirage une
pratique souvent encouragés dans ces
événements
mohamed el khayat et le confondateur
d'informatique br le principal revendeur
des tableaux smart
au québec l'entreprise prend part à
l'offensive pour faire connaître le
produit
avec mon équipe nous avons créé à que ce
tableau va prendre de l'espace va
prendre le marché l'avait anticipé on
anticiper on a formé les gens l'homme
d'affaires cumule les honneurs
ici il reçoit un prix de la ministre de
l'immigration il fait son entreprise un
modèle de succès et d'intégration il est
beaucoup de monde c'est quelqu'un qui a
un très bon car même les québécois c'est
pas juste les marocains ont obéi à la
communauté maghrébine
eb air dont l'essentiel de la clientèle
est dans le secteur public est apprécié
pour son service
c'est une petite compagnie mais était
très importante au québec dont
l'éducation l'entreprise tissent des
liens étroits avec les commissions
scolaires depuis des années trop de
liens selon certains témoins et ex
employés qui ont vu chez eux br des
pratiques douteuses informatique br à la
réputation de choyer ses clients par
exemple lors de son tournoi de golf
auquel sont invités des employés du
secteur public
il y avait des gens de différentes
commissions scolaires en effet surtout
les directeurs informatiques
l'inscription la location d'équipement
nourriture boissons j'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un débourser quoi que ce soit
c'était des bons ce prix il y avait
facilement une cinquantaine de clients
une activité commandité également par
ibm
toujours selon nos témoins le br a aussi
amené des employés du secteur public
dont certains du milieu de l'éducation
dans une loge du centre bell pour voir
jouer le canadien les bons vivants ce
qui m est fait à gratter aimait beaucoup
et br mais les gens qui étaient très
strictes vaille de bouc plusieurs fermé
la porte à b
br été reconnu pour ses parts et bien
arrosée lors de congrès en éducation
l'entreprise avait l'habitude de louer
une suite pour y accueillir ses clients
il y avait comme une clique des clients
qui quand c'est un fait les amener aux
danseuses des gens commissions scolaires
oui offrir des cadeaux s'était répandue
jetez pas tout le monde mais il y en
avait beaucoup
à chaque tournoi de golf on avait
quelques vélos à monter d'ex employés
disque br n'était pas la seule à choyer
ses clients ces pratiques discutables et
dangereux parce qu'on se fasse dans des
situations de vulnérabilité pour les
tice et andré lacroix les pratiques
décrites par les témoins sans être
illégal sont préoccupantes
ce que ce payx jusqu'à 20 $ ce que je
peux accepter jusqu'à 50 dollars alors
que la réalité c'est à quoi ça amène ce
cadeau-là quoi satexpo ce qu'elle
voulait on donne pas le cadeau pour rien
en quelque sorte on en donne pour
remercier pour créer une habitude pour
créer un plaisir
puis tranquillement l'amener saudeau
terrain qu'un au final l'achat
après la pause d'autres ennuis pour br
et la journaliste marie france bélanger
sera avec nous
au printemps 2014 informatique br en
caisse un coup dur le grand patron est
arrêté tout comme haut fonctionnaire du
ministère de la sécurité publique
ils sont accusés d'avoir mis en place un
stratagème frauduleux
l'année suivante deuxième perquisition
de nouvelles accusations sont portées
contre l'homme d'affaires et ses
présumés complices deux fonctionnaires
de revenu québec aurait transmis de
l'information privilégiée à un
consortium formé de deux fournisseurs
informatiques soit au br et i'll be nbr
ne peut plus décrocher des contrats du
gouvernement
c'est la fin de l'entreprise c'était un
vrai choc
soit on dépasse la vérité j'ai pas creux
parce que c'est juste des accusations
ces deux causes qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le monde de l'éducation sont
maintenant devant les tribunaux par
l'entremise de son avocat mohamed el
khayat à nier les pratiques décrites par
nos témoins l'autre fondateur de br lui
admet que ses activités ont eu cours
jusqu'en 2014 mais qu'elle était
financée par certains manufacturiers
comme ibm de vol
le jeune belle et si vous toujours à
l'aise avec ces pratiques lot
par contre il dit qu'il n'aurait jamais
toléré des sorties aux danseuses
de son côté smart technology a refusé de
répondre à nos questions br n'est plus
mais des soirées ont toujours lieu lors
de congrès en éducation fin novembre
fournisseurs et responsables
informatiques sont réunis pour un
cocktail dînatoire bar ouvert les faits
commission charbonneau se feraient
sentir
l'organisateur new zik l'activité
n'était ni cacher ni extravagante et
qu'elle était d'effrayer par plusieurs
entreprises et non une seule
en éducation comme ailleurs la
sensibilisation aux bonnes pratiques ne
fait que commencer